at the start of the movie Gia the son of
an oligarch paval comes out of a club
with an eccentric woman he notices his
car being towed Away by a truck Furious
he follows the truck and verbally curses
the driver to stop just then he gets hit
by something in the back due to which he
passes out right then and there after
regaining Consciousness Gia mysteriously
finds himself in a stable in an
abandoned Village the stable is located
on a landowner's estate in the Russian
Empire seemingly it is the summer of
1860 6 months before the abolition of
them the status of many peasants under
feudalism a man named Arium who is
dressed in ragged clothes hurries him to
get the horses ready for the landowner
or the Lord Kisha dressed in similar
shabby clothing is understandably
shocked by the sight of his new
surroundings he tries to make sense of
the situation but is soon interrupted by
another man named Abdi who turns out to
be the right-hand man of the Lord Abdi
drags gisha outside the stable and
swears at him for not following the
Lord's orders moments after the Lord
appears at the scene and asks him why
his horses aren't ready yet initially
the Arrogant Gia thinks that this is a
trick and boasts his father's name to
threaten the Lord and his men however
the surrounding reality and the people
in it seem too real and convincing and
now he is a surf a horse groom surfs are
the lowest of class in a feudalistic
society and the landlords make them
slaves in exchange for food and shelter
brisha realizes that he has really
traveled back in time much worse he is
afraid of horses and therefore unable to
perform his duties the Arrogant brat
then tries to run away but is sadly
caught by the landlord's men he is then
tied with metal chains and dragged to
the Village Square to be punished on the
way gisha repeatedly demands to see his
lawyer but the Village People are
certainly unaware of the modern law when
they arrive at the square gisha sees
another man hanging in front of him this
is when he realizes that he too is going
to be hanged for not obeying the orders
reality finally dots him and he soon
surrenders to his fade just before he
has given the death penalty gisha
remembers his past life in a flashback
we learned learn that gisha is the son
of oligarch paval and lives a privileged
Life as a spoiled prick he frequents
nightclubs engages in casual
relationships with women and indulges in
his desires without facing any
consequences during a night at the club
gisha playfully flirts with a gorgeous
woman named anasa but she teases him for
his cliche approach in response to the
challenge gisha goes to the upscale
drinks section pours a drink and
shatters the remaining glasses with
champagne he then presents the drink to
the Pretty Woman a erting that no one
else in the room has the same drink as
hers intrigued the woman then engages in
a romantic conversation with him later
Gia and anasa hop into his fancy car
where he demands oral sex from her anasa
is disgusted so she refuses to follow
his orders the egotistic brat kicks her
out of his vehicle and decides to head
home as usual Gish crosses the speed
limit and is followed by police vans
since he is used to getting out of these
kinds of situations he shows no respect
for the law and police enforcement
however he is forced to stop his car at
one point because the newly transferred
officer who has been chasing him for a
while now seems determined to catch this
spoiled brat bisha plays his usual card
as he tries to bribe the officer however
the honest officer isn't willing to
accept the Brat's corrupted money
despite this gisha refuses to obey and
continues his way home the officer is
also unwilling to back down so he climbs
on top of Gia's car urging him to get
out of the vehicle immediately they
eventually end up in a very bad accident
due to which the the police officer is
severely injured Arisha is taken into
custody forcing his father paval to come
for Aid the police chief at the station
who turns out to be Pav's friend reminds
him of his son's unlawful actions he
also asserts that this will be the last
time he will be helping paval get his
son out of trouble the chief further
reveals that gisha has broken many rules
this month and he is certainly getting
out of control haval then realizes that
G's recklessness is only escalating he
has to find a way to treat his son's
irresponsible Behavior after getting him
out of custody paval threatens Gia to
cut his monthly allowances and also
block his credit cards however the
recess prick fires back rudely asking
his dad to rather focus on his business
concerned for his son's future paval
seeks a way to make him a better person
he meets Anastasia or just Anna a TV
producer and friend with benefits and
she suggests Consulting Lev arnoldovich
Lev is a psychologist known for
employing Effective though
unconventional methods for treating his
patients left with no choice C decides
to go with the plan to meet Lev when he
and Anna arrive at Lev's dark and creepy
apartment they find him hanging by a
rope the pair is understandably scared
and worried however it all turns out to
be a part of L's experiment he reveals
that he is working on a film project
that requires him to create realistic
scenarios he also works with individual
clients to help them deal with their
problems by employing such genuine but
fake scenes that cater to the client's
needs the scene then cuts to the night
when Gia had chased after his towed car
just then a mysterious person attacks
him from the back causing him to fall
into a deep Slumber we are then taken to
the present where gisha is begging for
forgiveness while the men around him
prepare to punish him fortunately for
him the daughter of the landowner AGA
intervenes in the situation she pleads
to her father and her brother Alexi to
Halt the execution for a day because it
is the occasion of her Nam day today
since her father loves her too much he
agrees to Pardon Gia for his crimes the
prickly brat then accepts his fate as he
looks at the vulture in the sky that
that was ready to eat his meat
unbeknownst to him the vulture is a
drone operated from a windmill across a
distance inside it we see a whole team
of modern humans working on what seems
to be a film set it is then revealed
that the 19th Century Village is a
carefully crafted production funded by
paval and orchestrated by Anna and
psychologist Lev arnoldovich all the
villagers are actually actors working
under the guidance of Anna and her
production team the project aims to
transform Gia's perspectives on the
world and himself with the team closely
monitor in his every action while the
recreation of 1860s Russia isn't
Flawless G's lack of knowledge about
Russian history prevents him from
noticing the anachronisms ensuring the
Project's success despite initially
resisting the idea of being thrust into
the past Gia gradually accepts his role
as a surf in this timeline he then
attempts to navigate the unfamiliar
position in his own way the project
script envisions GCA starting a romance
with AA leading to a surf eloping with a
lady Cal Anna and the psychologist
believe that it would bring about
significant change in life attitudes the
actor who plays AGA in this Village
follows the script and tries to get G's
attention she manages to entice him when
she sits alone and cries by the Hal Loft
she Wordly reveals that her father is
forcing her to marry an older wealthy
land owner however gisha doesn't connect
with the plight of the young woman being
coerced into marrying a rich landowner
he instead says that AGA can take all of
her husband's wealth once he passes away
brisha continues to be an arrogant man
and does not sympathize with others in
one instance he steals one of A's
chickens and makes a Sumptuous dinner
for himself Abdi soon learns about the
missing chicken so he rounds up all the
Surfs and demands to know the culprit as
anticipated gisha doesn't reveal himself
therefore AI randomly chooses another
Surf and punishes him meanwhile the
spoiled brat watches the drama unfold
without any remorse on his face
frustrated by G's lack of progress paval
plans to terminate the project however
there is a Twist in events when gisha
notices a beautiful Village girl named
Lisa when she gets off the horse he
takes notice of the girl's red
Victoria's Secret underwear bisha
immediately approaches her and
inappropriately attempts to make sure of
what he saw surprisingly he sees her
naked body underneath the skirt while
the villagers reprimand his actions it
turns out that Lisa quickly took off her
underwear and threw it under the hay to
make sure that gisha doesn't have any
suspicions later gisha apologizes to
Lisa after recognizing the severity of
his actions surprised by this change in
his son's attitude paval de decides to
continue with the project as time passes
by gisha develops a genuine connection
with Lisa prompting the psychologist to
alter the story line making Lisa the
object of Gia's affection despite
initially disliking gisha Lisa agrees to
help him change along the way gisha
undergos a transformation witnessing his
own flaws merried in Alexi who turns out
to be leisa's real life boyfriend Anton
Giga played by Pina upset about losing
the lead role manipulates Anton into
thinking Lisa plans to have an affair
with Gia their conversation takes a
heated turn when they end up having an
intimate encounter with each other much
to their embarrassment their lovemaking
session is witnessed by Lisa and gisha
since Anton is Lisa's real life
boyfriend she is visibly miserable
however gisha unaware of the truth
surmises that AGA and Alexia are in an
incestuous relationship in the meantime
Lev the psychologist is shocked by the
unexpected revelation of incest
therefore he removes AGA and Alexi from
the roles in retaliation Pina exposes
the project to the mainstream media and
eventually to the world claiming that a
man is being tortured soon after this
Revelation the police launch an
investigation with Pina aiding them as
the police close in on the project a
last minute plan is devised to transform
G's attitude once and for all a staged
invasion of 19th century Russia by the
golden horde the Mongols from the
Northwestern sector of the Mongol Empire
unaware of the project gisha remains
oblivious as the actors playing the
golden horde arrive at the village and
abduct Lisa gisha initially reverts to
his selfish and cowardly Behavior
seemingly jeopardizing the entire
project by fleeing however he has a
change of heart when he realizes his
true feelings for Lisa he comes to
senses that he has always been running
away from trouble however this is the
time for him to make a different
decision at least once in his life bisha
then returns to confront the Invaders
and fight off the Mongol Army ultimately
rescuing Lisa the pair then escape on
Horseback just minutes before the police
arrive at the village since Gia has
already left the scene the police
mistake the entire Village for a
historical film set in the meantime Gia
and Lisa travel a significant distance
on Horseback before finally reaching a
gas station he is understandably shocked
to see a normal modern word outside the
19th Century Village suddenly a member
of Hest team uses a tranquilizer to
incapacitate Gia causing him to lose
Consciousness when he wakes up he's
informed that he experienced a 3-month
coma and that the surf's past and
Village were all part of an illusion
despite maintaining his character
development gisha realizes that Lisa was
never real plunging him into a deep
depression eventually gisha encounters
Pina and Anton the actors portraying AGA
and Alexi in a nightclub confused he
approaches them and asks them about
their whereabouts Pina and Anton realize
that gisha is still unaware of the
experiment on him out of pity they
reveal the truth about the project and
confirm Lisa's existence gisha then
locates Lisa and they reunite with open
arms while paval and Donna who had
feelings for each other for far too long
tie the knot in the film's final scene
another oligarch son is thrust into the
village deceived into believing he has
traveled back to feudal Russia Gia now
part of the project team observes the
unfolding drama